hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast structure and function of
the human microbiome I'm Bob Woodard and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
this because we are delighted to bring
you this presentation presented by lab
roots you can learn more about athletes
by visiting ww-what can before we begin
the presentation I have a few important
announcements to make first of all this
is intended to be an interactive event
you're encouraged to submit questions
and comments during the presentation you
can do that by clicking on the green Q&A
button the lower left for the
presentation window and type in your
question and comments into the Q&A box
that appears on the screen also if you'd
like to enlarge the slide window during
the presentation click on the slide icon
lower right at the slide window and
finally if you have technical
difficulties hearing or viewing this
presentation please click on the support
button on the upper right of the
presentation window or let us know using
the green Q&A button and we'll try to
resolve the situation as quickly as
possible okay that's it for that now I'd
like to introduce today's speaker dr.
Curtis Fenton our dr. Hutton Hauer is an
associate professor of computational
biology and bioinformatics at the
Harvard th Chan School of Public Health
and an associate member at the Broad
Institute he received his PhD from
Princeton University where he also
performed his postdoctoral research at
the Louis Ziegler Institute he was an
analysis lead in the NIH human
microbiome project and currently
co-leads the HMP two Center for
characterizing the gut microbial
ecosystem inflammatory bowel disease dr.
Hutton Howard's lab focuses on
computational methods for functional
analysis of microbial communities this
includes systems biology reconstruction
that integrates metagenomic
that a transcript on me and other
microbial community omics
the human microbiome in autoimmune
diseases such as IBD and as potential as
a diagnostic tool and point of
therapeutic intervention please join me
in welcoming dr. Hutton our to today's
event I will now turn the presentation
over to him great thanks so much Bob
thanks the lab roots for hosting today
and everyone for joining especially
anyone starting off the day bright and
early from the west coast I'd like to
provide a little bit of introduction
today to the human microbiome I'll talk
about the ecology of the human
microbiome the NIH human microbiome
project and follow-up that we and others
have been doing and somebody analysis
methods and tools that are used to study
microbial communities so one of the
reasons that my group at the Harvard
School of Public Health is excited about
working on human microbiome stems from
the body that you're looking at here
this is featured on the cover of one of
our introductory biostatistics textbooks
and for those of you who didn't bring
your magnifying glasses to the
presentation today I can use a slightly
more modern version of this plot that
shows deaths from infectious disease
over the past couple of centuries
specifically in New York City and if you
follow the general contour of the plot
you can see that infectious disease
caused by specific pathogens over the
previous century was one of the leading
causes of death in New York and of
course globally but then within the past
century or so advances in microbiology
and in Public Health practice have
reduced infectious disease pathogen
driven disease to a relatively minor
source of mortality and morbidity in the
developed world something that's really
come to life in the past several decades
though is the corresponding rise in
non-pathogen driven but microvilli
linked chronic disease and this is a
widely used fought from review
several years ago now that shows the
rise in a range of different autoimmune
linked diseases over the past several
decades of course much too quickly to be
explained by human genetics and instead
is speaking to changes in our
interaction with our microbial
environment and of course over the same
span of time several environmental
factors that modulate our immune systems
interaction with both typical and
pathogenic microbes have changed as well
ranging from where we live and work the
types of foods that we eat the
antimicrobial and probiotics that works
follows to along with other
pharmaceuticals howling age and even our
day-to-day stress levels of course the
human microbiome in particular has been
studied for quite a bit longer than that
some of the earliest microscopy like
these illustrations that you're looking
at here was performed by then Lewin
hooked several hundred years ago
investigating under the very first
microscope microbes from his own saliva
but the microbiome has become even more
closely scrutinized in just the past few
years due to one other plot that we can
look at the features are dramatically
changing lime which is of course the
cost and throughput of nucleotide
sequencing so by taking advantage of the
efficiency and effectiveness of modern
high-throughput nucleotide sequencing
methods we can use DNA and increasingly
RNA sequencing as a tool to get a better
perspective on the human microbiome and
how it might factor in these rapid
changes in chronic autoimmune disease so
to establish some of the terminology
that that out that I and others will use
over the course of the day some of the
earliest work in microbial communities
occurred about a hundred years ago now
in the literature at which point
collections of microbes within a
community were referred to as micro
flora this is a term that you won't see
very often anymore instead you'll see
things like microbial community or
microbiota and all of these terms
particularly microbiota now are used to
refer to a collection of organisms and
this typically spans not just bacteria
but viruses eukaryotic microbes
such as fungi and archaea within a
community fast forward about 75 years
from there to the point at which
high-throughput sequencing was beginning
to take off and the term meta-genome was
coined to refer specifically to the
collection of DNA or the genomic
potential of a microbial community a few
years later the term microbiome finally
showed up as well to refer to a
community's total molecular repertoire
or its local ecology so you can think of
the microbiome as the collection not
only of specific organisms but of their
DNA their RNA their biomolecules their
metabolites and their immediate
surroundings such that metagenomics as a
field is overall the culture independent
study of microbial communities be they
from literally the environment soil or
water or from a host associated
environment such as the human microbiome
so sequencing has become one of the main
tools used to study culture independent
microbial communities and to provide a
brief overview of how this is performed
given a microbial sample it's typically
lysed by breaking open the cells
extracting nucleotides most often DNA
but again increasingly RNA to look at
transcripts as well as genomes and then
performing one of two main types of
sequencing either amplicon sequencing in
which PCR is used to amplify a single
marker gene of interest this is most
often the 16s RNA which is a bacterial
Universal subunit of the ribosome such
that all of your sequencing throughput
is used to sequence variants in a
specific gene variants at a specific
locus each small nucleotide variant can
then be used to classify that sequence
to its microbial source sort of like a
microbial name tag by counting how many
times you see each sequencing variant at
that one amplified locus amplicon
sequencing or 16s sequencing as it's
most often referred to generates data
that look like these where for each
sample
you get a list of which microbes are
prison and that counts or relative
abundances at which these are they occur
again 16s RNA gene and pecans are most
often used to target bacterial
communities increasing you increasingly
you'll see the 18s RNA subunit for I TS
internal transcribed spacer amplicons
used to target fungal eukaryotic
microbial communities as well
alternatively meta genomic or meta
transcriptomic sequencing just sequences
everything this results in a pile of
short reads much as you would sequence
for a single genome isolate and this can
provide a more complete picture of what
the total genomic potential of a
community have looked like at the cost
of a little bit more complexity and it
will see a little bit later on a little
more computational interpretation to
help analyze the data but as a result
you can see not just a taxonomic profile
of which microbes are present like you
might from amplicon sequencing but a
functional profile of what's a
metabolism pathways are present in the
community you can assemble context or
increasingly near whole genomes from a
meta genome and this provides you an
idea of which genomes what gene content
and even a few sequence enough or have a
simple enough community what types of
genetic variants might be present and
increasingly especially in the context
of public health epidemiology style my
microbiome experiments will integrate
both of these types of sequencing along
with other culture independent or
culture based molecular tools to study
microbial communities this lets you
answer a variety of different questions
often by slicing the same dataset in
slightly different ways if you're
interested in this single specific
organisms you can zoom in on the
sequences or sequence variants from a
particular bug within a meta genome or
other culture independent sample so for
example in the human microbiome most of
us carry slightly different variants of
every organism so we might all have
slightly different eco eyes if you're
interested in equaling microbiology
you can zoom in on just the equalized
sequences from a collection of
metagenomes alternatively if you're
interested not in any one particular
organism but in the microbial ecology or
interactions within or among communities
you might zoom out a little and pay
attention to which microbes occur
together how they might be competing or
symbiotic within a community or what
their metabolic or signaling
interactions might be zooming up still
further if you're studying the human
microbiome you might not care about the
microbes at all but use the sequencing
readout as a high-throughput measure say
of boost health much as we've become
able to do it using cancer
transcriptomics as a high dimensional
diagnostic or prognostic readout and
finally at the opposite extreme if
you're interested in public health of
Epidemiology you might look at human
ecology or the interaction among
multiple human hosts or alternatively
environments so this helps to address
questions like how we acquire our
microbiome in the first place after
birth or how microbial communities are
transmitted horizontally later in life
all these speak to different biological
questions that can be asked with the
same techniques or often with the same
data sets or collections of datasets
surveying the human microbiome or other
microbial communities again in a culture
independent one of the largest studies
of the human microbiome today's has been
the NAHB GMT or human microbiome project
which was which had the mandate to
establish what the baseline human
microbiome looked like in the absence of
perturbations from disease the HMP ran
from originally from 2007 to 2012 and
has been succeeded by a follow-up HMP -
or integrative human microbiome project
that I'll speak about in just a bit the
HMP itself though to establish a
baseline of our normal microbial
variation recruited a population of 300
healthy subjects all of adult
excuse me half adult men and half adult
women because unlike our genome our
normal microbial populations vary a
great deal from person to person
these individuals were surveyed at up to
three different time points each add up
to 18 different body sites grouped into
five areas shown on the upper right the
nasal communities several different oral
communities several skin microbial
communities the gut is represented by a
stool sample and multiple different
vaginal sites in women these samples
were accompanied by clinical metadata
demographics and biometrics on these
individuals and all of the sequencing
data both amplicon and shotgun
metagenomes are available at the data
analysis and coordinating center shown
in the lower left the original series of
HMK publications included between five
and six thousand amplicon sequenced data
sets if you multiply out individuals x
time points x party sites and about 700
of metagenomes
surveying a subset of individuals time
points and body sites we've subsequently
sequenced another 500 or so metagenomes
resulting in a collection of over 1200
of metagenomes surveying 100 individuals
at almost all three time points each
again all of these first and second wave
data are available at the data analysis
of coordinating center and there's been
a series of publications released from
the HMP summarized at the nature
collection linked on this slide to
provide an overview of some of the
consortiums early results however we can
do layout and look at just the very
basic outline of what this survey of
microbial diversity told us about the
human microbiome what you're looking at
on the left here is a summary of the 18
body sites surveyed in the HMP connected
by line indicating how similar the
overall microbial communities or theta
diversity of the authority sites was on
average across the whole population so
body sites that tended to contain the
same types and abundances of microbes
are connected by stronger lines you'll
see that these groups the microbial
communities into several different
clusters by biogeography including are
several oral sites on the right which
grouped into three
collections the hardest surfaces of the
tooth just above and below the gum line
on the lower right middle several
different frontal and distal soft
tissues on the upper right and then at
the other end of the GI tract the gut
microbiome is quite this thing that has
been perhaps the most closely studied
area of the human microbiome will speak
to that a little bit later on since it's
by far the air the region in which we
carry the greatest microbial load and it
is the it represents the greatest
exposure of our immune system to
commensal microbes on the upper left we
have several different skin sites as
you'll see in the next few slides these
tended to be the most variable both over
time and among individuals most likely
because they're more exposed to the
environment it's easy to for example
wash our hands and change which microbes
we have on our skin and then on the
lower left the three different vaginal
communities the three different vaginal
body sites surveyed for female subjects
tended to be very similar to each other
in terms of microbial ecology and we'll
see why that is in a few slides as well
we can expand these summarized
relationships however and fill in a
little bit of the population density of
this broad outline what you're looking
at here is an ordination of all 5,000 or
so amplicon datasets generated during
the first wave of the HMP such that now
each point represents just one sample
and they're closer to each other if
their overall microbial communities are
more similar so this helps to expand out
the summary that we're seeing on the
left and you can see that of the many
different oral body sites surveyed even
though there's diversity throughout the
oral community at different locations
they're generally more similar to each
other than to different body sites and
then on the left there's a range of
microbial diversity from the skin and
nasal sites which were somewhat similar
to each other the very front of the
nostrils was sampled during the HMP so
it looks very much like a skin site
through the vaginal communities to be
again very distinct depth communities on
that top middle to continue zooming in
to a little bit more the ecology of
these
voles terminally ill probably here
several times today include alpha and
beta diversity alpha diversity in
microbial ecology represents the number
of different organisms within a
community and how evenly they're
distributed so if you have many
different organisms and they are
comparably abundant to each other you
can refer to that community as highly
alpha difference similarly if you have
just a few organisms or just a few
organisms that are more abundant that
community and less alpha difference so
what you're looking at here is a summary
of the Alpha diversity or within
community diversity across the 18 body
sites of the HMP and the box plots the
vertical range of each box summarizes
the span of alpha diversity across the
300 individuals in this healthy
population but three different colors
represent both our two different data
types amplicon or 16s sequencing and
meta genomic or whole genome shotgun WGS
as its summarized here metagenomic
sequencing these amplicon sequencing was
processed in two slightly different ways
computationally to understand either
direct classification of these sequences
or phyla types or cluster based
classification of these sequences or
operational taxonomic units ot use
fortunately all three of these excuse me
both of these data types and all three
different ways of processing them tend
to agree with each other very closely
when surveying the alpha diversity of
our 18 different body sites you'll see
in the middle of the slide the
gastrointestinal tract including both
the gut and the oral community tended to
be more alpha diverse we tend to have
more bugs at these microvilli accessible
mucosal nutrient-rich sites and then
areas like the skin were again less
alpha diverse and in this case for
reasons we'll again see in a few slides
the vaginal microbiome was particularly
low diversity as we'll see a little bit
later the vaginal McFadden tends to be
dominated in many individuals by just a
few organisms so again that's reflected
in a lower alpha diversity
the next type of microbial diversity
that's quantified and in microbial
ecology is beta diversity or within
forces me between community diversity so
beta diversity represents how similar or
different to separate microbial
communities are so if individuals tend
to have mostly the same organisms at the
same abundances between the two
different communities then we'll say
that they are less beta diverse if those
two communities tend to be more
different
we'll say that there are more data
difference so beta diversity acts like a
distance or a correlation measure it
tells you how similar or different two
communities are rather than summarizing
the properties of one community the way
that alpha diversity was that was excuse
me so for example on the left side of
this slide you can see that the
differences between skin communities
among individuals tend to be pretty high
so like I said earlier the skin
community is a little easier to disrupt
it's a little sparser and so when you
look from person to person you'll often
see different organisms thus resulting
again no matter how the data are
processed in a higher theta diversity on
the skin this is less true in the
gastrointestinal tract even though we
tend to have more bugs in our GI tract
the oral and deaf communities they're
more often similar although as we'll see
in a few slides more similar still means
quite different from person to person
and then finally on the right hand side
here you'll see an interesting property
of the vaginal community
if we look at our amplicon or 16s data
using direct classification or phyla
types these represent approximately a
genus level classification of the
sequences and there are relatively few
differences among the general of
microbes carried in the vaginal
community so the red boxes on the right
tend to be very low however if we use
operational taxonomic units or booty use
that cluster or amplicon sequences to a
slightly higher level of specificity we
start to see more differences it turns
out that in the vaginal community
many individuals not all but many tend
to carry predominantly microbes from the
genus lactobacillus but they'll often be
different species from within that genus
such that if we classify those sequences
more precisely in the yellow boxes we
see more differences between individuals
and then finally using our shotgun data
to get a very precise level of taxonomic
classification the blue box on the right
hand side is even higher so this speaks
to the different ways you can slice the
same data sets like I referred to
earlier if we ask the question do
individuals tend to carry the same
microbial generat in the vaginal
community the answer is yes and they're
less favorite averse if we ask the
question do individuals tend to carry
the same strains of microbes within the
vaginal community the answer is no and
our blue box shows more data diversity
so we'll see different ways of analyzing
microbial community data over the course
of the talk I would have speak to this a
little bit by describing some of our
pipelines for analyzing shotgun
meta-genome and meta transcriptome data
and several of these are built on a
collection of tools referred to as the
flan tools or phylogenetic analysis
originally started by Nicholas igano and
he was a postdoc with Peru he has his
own lab at the University of Toronto now
where he's continued a series of
computational methods development for
assembly free meta-genome and meta
transcriptome analysis this relies on
the intuition that we can use microbial
isolates genome information to analyze
microbial community meta-genome
information so Nicholas started with two
sets of data referred to here as a repo
plan and choco flan built on the total
collection of microbial isolate genomes
currently available at the NCBI this
includes not just bacteria but again
archaea viruses and eukaryotic microbes
primarily fungi and stands both draft
and complete genomes totaling about
twenty thousand genomes right now we're
getting on the order of a thousand new
Mike
Williams per month so this is a
tremendously powerful tool for turning
those isolate genomes into information
about communities repo plan is a system
that downloads these genomes organizes
them perform some quality control and
filtering and taxonomic reclassification
and then identifies the protein coding
and other open reading frame genes in
this collection which is currently just
about 50 million open reading frame
doors the user then catalogued by a
second system referred to as Chaco plan
or the catalog of homologous clusters of
gene families which extracts the open
reading frame collections from each
issues to create a panda genome this
currently spans just over 60 X 80 7600
species and totals about 20 million gene
family clusters these are then annotated
with phylogenetic and functional
information including which genes are
core that is conserved throughout a
particular species or clade and which of
those core genes are unique markers the
unique marker genes are among the most
taxonomically informative because they
are carried by all members of a species
or clade and they are not carried by
other organisms so each time we see a
sequence from these unique marker genes
in particular we know which organism it
came from and this provides one way to
turn shotgun meta genomic information
into a taxonomic profile counting up
which bugs are there just like you might
with amplicon sequencing data Nicola put
this together in a tool called meta plan
and what you're looking at here is a
taxonomic survey of the first 700
metagenomes
from the human microbiome using meta
plan each column represents one
meta-genome the body sites from which
they're drawn are annotated along the
top of the slide in color and each row
represents the relative abundance of one
of organism across those
hundred samples this represents just a
slice off the top of the most abundant
organisms throughout the human
microbiome going from left to right if
we just naively cluster these you'll see
that the major driver of microbial
composition in the human microbiome is
biogeography is the body site from which
that community is drawn in the upper
left orange represents the nasal
communities with a few other skin
communities mixed in the next three
colors are from the oral microbiome
respectively green from the tunnel red
from the cheek and brown from the tooth
surface and again while these are quite
distinct from each other you'll see that
they're more like each other than they
are other body sites just as we saw
earlier purple represents the gut and
blue on the lower right represents the
vaginal microbiomes now I want to zoom
in on an example from the gut and
vaginal communities in particular since
a few years ago a collection of
high-profile publications originally in
nature and later picked up by other
scientific journals such as the New York
Times raised the hypothesis that we can
organize the complexity of microbial
ecology in the gut into just a few
discrete types and to provide an example
of what this might look like the vaginal
community felt appear to be organized
this way if we zoom in on the 50 or so
metagenomes from the posterior fornix
one of the vaginal sites surveyed by the
HMP and we look at just the abundant
species in these communities you'll see
that there are four clusters each
dominated by a particular lactobacillus
species so going from left to right here
we have lactobacillus Chris fattest
lactobacillus chance nei black widow
Celestine arisen lactobacillus Caesarea
there's a fifth cluster over on the
right hand side represented by just a
few individuals in this population that
lacks any lactobacilli and instead has a
diversity of other methods these five
quite distinct community types kept
record pretty reliably in the vaginal
microbiome across different populations
and in each one either your dominated by
a particular lactobacillus species and
lack
the others or you lack all lactobacillus
species
so this organizes the complexity of the
vaginal ecology into five main community
types the hypothesis was that you could
do something similar for the gut but you
can see even by eye that this type of
microbial organization doesn't seem to
care in the gut and if we zoom in to a
higher level of detail in both the HMP
gut meta-genome and a collection of
similar metagenomes from the netiquette
project which is a parallel european
project we'll see that there doesn't
seem to be that type of discrete
clustered of organization there's a
great deal of diversity differences in
which microbes are abundant from
individual to individual and there are
certainly microbes that are quite
abundant in several different
individuals but if we ordinate these
samples again this is a visualization in
which communities are projected into a
two-dimensional flame each point
represents one of the microbial
community and the more similar they are
the closer they appear on the ordination
you'll see that there don't appear to be
discrete clusters except in one case and
we'll talk about that in just a second
instead there's a continuum a smear of
communities ranging from those that tend
to carry most members of the factories
or more generally the phylum factories
one of the two main groups of microbes
in the gut down to individuals that
carry relatively few bacteria teas and
mostly members of the phylum Firmicutes
instead the exception is this out group
here which are individuals that tend to
carry specifically members of the genus
Privitera
so this is something that that occurs
pretty reliably across Western
populations other parts of the world are
a little bit different in terms of gut
microbial ecology but in this particular
case we have a subset about 10% of the
population that looks more like the
vaginal microbiome organization if you
have for the Toa and in this case
specifically private ella capri it's
abundant and you're depleted for other
organisms this results if you quantify
that the cluster structure in the data
in two reliable clusters in the gut
microbiome Prevotella
and everything else as
opposed to the five very reliable
clusters we saw in the vaginal
microbiome this is work in quantifying
this intuition rather than just relying
on our eyeballs that was carried out by
Levi Waldron and my group in a
collaboration with Ruth lamb and Rob
Knights group interestingly in this
particular example we do reliably see
this Privitera
out group in other populations and we've
since gone on and worked with Dan Lipton
to show that it's associated with new
onset untreated rheumatoid arthritis so
this is an ordination of a completely
separate population that Dan recruited
in New York in which we have the same
greedy --nt from high to low back three
DS carriers the same out group of
further teller carriers and that out
group is enriched for new onset
rheumatoid arthritis patients we don't
yet know the causality we don't know if
you're at greater risk of RA due to
private electorate or if the onset of RA
increases for the teller carriage but
we're going on to do some mouse
experiments with Dan to try to tease
that apart continuing to zoom in however
we look so far it's species-level taxa
nomic profiles from meta-genome using
meta phlegm we recently completed a
second version of the tool meta plan -
that includes not just bacterial and
archaeal sequences but also viruses and
eukaryotes and which allows you to zoom
all the way into some species are often
stream level microbial profiling this is
an example from a collection of skin
metagenomes into which we've zoomed in a
little more detail here you're familiar
with skin microbiology you'll see
several of the usual bacterial suspects
but also scattered throughout here
examples like malassezia globosa towards
the middle of the plot which is a common
skin fungal microbe and down towards the
bottom several viruses specifically
Propionibacterium phage and different
variants of that theta that occur in
Propionibacterium hosts in the different
human hosts if we continue to zoom in to
this type of taxonomic profile we can
actually identify different strains of
microbes carried stabili by different
individuals what you're looking at here
is an example from the vaginal
microbiome in which the unique marker
team
for lactobacillus for status have been
under roll so from left to right in this
plot you're looking at several hundred
different loci across the lactobacillus
Chris fattest genome that we have
evidence we have reason to believe from
isolate genomes come specifically from
lactobacillus response we don't see
these sequences in other microbes
however not all lactobacillus response
strains
tarry exactly the same genes microbe
microbial genomes are much more istick
than our own such that in these two
individuals with three time points
represented in the top individual and
two time points represented in the
bottom individual we can see slight
variations in which genomic loci are
present both between these individuals
lactobacillus crostata strains and
between these strains and the reference
pan genome that we have provide the
visit was Chris vadas so several of the
marker losada that differ between these
two strains have been indicated by red
arrows here and you can see that for the
most part over these 10 points spanning
about six months of different each this
same the strain is carried by each
individual there's one change in the
lower individual in which one of the
genomic loci which looks to be a mobile
element has been picked up and modified
such as the stream change is a very
slight light but for the most part not
only in the vaginal microbiome but
across different strains of different
microbes at different body sites this is
a general property of the human
microbiome we all have slightly
different strains of most organisms and
in our adult life over moderate periods
of saying months to a few years these
strains tend to be pretty stable this is
interesting in as much as a postdoc in
my group now a research scientist Eric
friend Sosa was able to quantify the
degree to which our microbes really are
personalized and unique so in work with
Brendan Bohannon at the University of
Oregon and captain lemon of course at
Institute here in Boston Eric asked the
question can we construct sets of
features that uniquely and stabili
separate different individuals like
five different individuals based not on
our DNA but on our microbial DNA and you
can think of features as including
either specific microbes which fugly
fairy microbial demons like we just saw
which low sigh are present in our
microbial strains or microbial variants
individual polymorphisms need a lot of
sequencing to get that type of
information from a whole community so
any such set of features will refer to
as a medical nick fingerprint you can
combine microbes or microbial genes or
microbial snips to try to separate out
who ident uniquely identify individuals
in a population so I won't go into the
algorithm that Eric used to construct
metabolic fingerprints but I'll provide
a brief overview of the results here
either using taxa on the left from the
amplicon or 16s data in the human
microbiome project taxonomic profiles at
the species level in the middle from our
shotgun metagenomes or combinations of
marker genes like we just saw on the
right hand side and you'll see that if
you try to separate individuals just by
which bugs they have at the buteo or
species level often we can't uniquely
separate individuals they're the
alphabet or the number of different bugs
it's a little too small but on the right
hand side if we consider which genes are
carried in combination by our microbes
were often able to construct codes which
would separate out individuals and
comparing the blue versus red bars on
the right hand side those codes are
often stable over time so what we're
looking for here are red bars that
represent true positive identification
of individuals using metal make
fingerprints made in this case from
marker gene combinations that are stable
over multiple time points so these are
represented by red farms if we lose an
individual we say here is a code for
somebody but it's gone at the next time
point that's represented by a blue bar
and then false positives in which a code
miss identifies the wrong individual are
shown in cyan and
four hole on the right-hand side
unfortunately those bars are small so
most often ranging from about a third of
the time and the trickier body sites
like the skin up to about 75 to 80% of
the time in a more stable body site like
the gut we can construct a code based on
the screen level identification of
combinations of marker genes the
uniquely identifies an individual and as
as shown across the bottom here is
stable over time there's relatively
little effective time intervals on the
order of weeks two months to a year or
two in these particular data on the
ability of these codes to uniquely
separate out individuals so just like we
can use variants in our own DNA to tell
one person from another to a degree we
can use variants in our microbial DNA to
tell one individual from another so this
helps to start explain why our
microbiomes are so distinct from each
other if we acquire different organism
and they're relatively stable over time
and settle into different patterns of
strains that we each carry or say months
to years over the course of our adult
life that helps to create that higher
degree of theta diversity that we saw
earlier however something that's common
among individuals in the human
microbiome is the functional repertoire
needed to maintain a microbial community
at each environment so what you're
looking at here on the left-hand side on
the top is the differences at a high
level of a phylum level from individual
to individual in which microbes we carry
a different body sites however in each
of these same samples what you're
looking at on the lower left is the
collection of genes and pathways carried
by the same microbial communities at
each photo site at each sample and so if
we look at something like the gut blue
represents factory TVs so again we see
this continuum from individuals with a
whole bunch of back three deities down
to individuals with almost none but the
pathway is on the lower half of the plot
needed to maintain a healthy gut
microbial community are relatively
stable certainly different individuals
will carry bugs with different genes but
the overall metabolism and signaling and
regular
needed for that community is relatively
stable even though it's carried by
different phone in different individuals
this property has been observed in other
cohorts it's even been observed in other
hosts this is a great paper except that
it's not about the human microbiome at
all it's about all be associated
microbial communities and again this
ability to distribute responsibility to
distribute different metabolic or
regulatory needs among organisms is in
part explained by mechanisms of
plasticity like horizontal transfer that
are much more available to Micro than
they are to typical eukaryotic hosts so
in a way this distribution of genes and
pathways is the core human microbiome
not necessarily a distribution of
particular organisms and although I
won't go into it much today it's amazing
how much of this is microbial dark
matter how many of these sequences are
not yet functionally characterized we
don't necessarily yet know what they do
or how they get there or how they're
maintained over the longer period of
time but there's a lot that we do know
about the microbial metabolism and
regulation in the human microbiome and
and other communities all closed over
the next several minutes with a couple
of functional profiling tools and
examples that Lee and others have
developed one example that I'll speak to
briefly is called ashraf red or the
short better leave data set assembler
this is a functional profiling tool that
uses the same intuition that mehta flag
does in as much as we can identify
unique sequences from clustered protein
families of interest so if you have just
a few types of sequences that you're
interested in picking out of a meta to
no more meta transcript John shortbread
will take that list of sequences cluster
them into homologous families identify
just the unique regions that separate
each family from others and from other
proteins and then count up how often
those unique sequences occur in a meta
genome or meta transcriptome this is
developed by a master staff former
master student with the lab Jim Kaminsky
now about Berkeley PhD program and has
the benefit of being
for specific gene families of interest
faster and more specific so just like
meta plan focuses on just the sequences
that are taxonomically informative
sure Fred focuses on just the sub
sequences that are functionally
informative for particular protein
families event first so these might
include for example antibiotic
resistance sequences this is an example
of shortbread profiling that you did
with gout of dawn ptosis lab and his
student Molly Gibson at Washington
University combining three different
method gut meta-genome cohorts from the
HMP the global gut survey carried out by
Jeff Gordon's lab and the survey of type
2 diabetes subjects and Chinese gut
metagenomes identifying antibiotic
resistance sequences from the argb or
antibiotic resistance database in this
case and you can see that there's both
some consistency across these local gut
metagenomes
including tetracycline resistance
occurring in years at high pressure high
abundance and high prevalence and nearly
every gut meta-genome down to variants
that occur only in for example the
chinese subset of the population and
you'll see a little bit more about this
later in the day for antimicrobial
resistance profiling however if you're
interested in broader functional
profiling of metagenomes or meta
transcript jobs the tool that we've
developed for the HMP referred to as
human or in this case the second version
of that tool human to provide a broad of
functional profiling of any gene
families from human or other microbial
communities both meta-genome and meta
transcriptomes
human is built on the same collection of
genomes and genes that we saw earlier
rico planet Chaco flat that drive meta
plan to however instead of again using
just the most taxonomically informative
sequences like meta plan to does humans
who uses all functionally characterized
sequences from this catalog and will
efficiently profile the genes and
pathways in a meta genome are meta
transcriptome by starting first with a
survey of
most abundant microbes in that
metagenomic or meta transcriptomic
sample by lifting the pan genomes from
those abundant organisms out of choco
flan we can rapidly map nucleotide
sequences to them using bowtie 2 to
identify the gene families and bugs that
they're drawn from for sequences that
don't hit for reads that don't hit using
nucleotide laughing Hume on to next
performs a more general translated
search using diamond which is an
accelerated translated of last tool and
finally hits at either the nucleotide or
protein level are reassembled into
pathways using meta site by default the
human 2 can also use other pathway
databases such as unified waves or CAG
of those group interests so this results
in a list of which Gina families are
present in a sample their relative
abundances and when it when they can be
identified which microbes they're drawn
from these gene families are also
reassembled into pathways so just like
we typically get a taxonomic profile
from amplicon data or from metagenomes
using a tool like mehta plan to kill on
to provides a functional profile of
either gene or pathway relative
abundances or counts we can use that in
contexts like if the study of
inflammatory bowel disease getting back
to the original motivation for looking
at the human microbiome and its
association with complex chronic
autoimmune disease IBD inflammatory
bowel disease has become one of the
poster children for complex involvement
of the microbiome in chronic disease
over the past few years starting with
the observation that the gut microbiome
was involved somehow a few years ago
some general observations of disruption
or dysbiosis and microbial ecology and
then over the subsequent few years
refining that into more and more precise
observation of which microbes were
enriched or depleted during that disease
and how these varied among patients
subsets particularly between the two
major subsets of inflammatory bowel
disease Crohn's disease which you'll see
where
to a CD here we're all sort of colitis
which will see some abbreviated as you
see and I like to think of the
involvement of the microbiome in disease
very much like the involvement of human
genetics in as much as certain diseases
are genetically madelia cystic fibrosis
can be blamed on one particular locus
and certain infectious diseases are
actually certain diseases are infectious
are able to be blamed on a specific
pathogen other diseases are genetically
complex such as say type-2 diabetes and
other diseases are microbial II
conflicts such as inflammatory bowel
disease in as much as it can't be blamed
on one particular organism pathogen so
to help understand this complex
involvement of multiple microbes or the
full gut community in IBD we wanted to
ask the question which of these overall
ecological structural changes might be
functional and why how might they
associate with specific microbial
metabolic functions in specific subsets
of IBD
so we originally started looking at this
question a few years ago we've driven by
a research scientist in my lab such as
Morgan and a collaboration with Raman
Xavier at Mass General and abroad and
Bruce sands in New York first set of
cohorts that we looked at with a
combination of two cohorts from these
locations Oscar and prism totaling just
over 200 individuals from whom we had a
bit of again met accompanying metadata
and clinical background on their disease
progression and on treatments that they
had been exposed to we surveyed these
individuals using two different types of
samples for the gut microbiome both
stool samples and mucosal biopsies if
you look in the background of the slide
you can see the people again before the
nation of microbial similarity between
these 200 individuals
kind of separates out ulcerative colitis
and Crohn's disease a little bit from
our healthy controls but just disease
IBD the subset is not a major driver of
microbial diversity in these individuals
and as we expand out and formerly the
other environmental exposures that help
to explain this microbial very
you can see that there's a whole range
of things that affect the microbiome and
this is a general principle in as much
as things don't affect our genetics lots
of things affect our microbial
communities these range from how we
survey what type of sample we use to
look at the gut microbiome ranging from
mostly stool samples on the right to
mostly biopsies on the left treatment
exposures so for example in this cohort
you see patients more often receive
antibiotics and we can identify an
independent effect of antibiotics on the
gut microbiome it's different from what
ulcerative colitis alone has and then
similarly on the left Crohn's disease
patients more often received
immunosuppressive x' and those had
another different effect on the gut
microbiome finally along the diagonal
axis although it might be interesting to
look at the effects of smoking on the
gut microbiome in this case a much
larger effect with age we had subjects
ranging from pediatric Asians up through
older adults and the microbiome does a
very overtime particularly during
infancy and childhood such that what
we're seeing in that axis of microbial
variation is we think not smoking but
the fact that most of our healthy
controls were early there was an
enrichment of our healthy controls for
pediatric subjects which is free and
they were mostly non-smokers which is
also great such that we see microbial
variation due to age not smoking but
what we'd like to do is tease apart just
the effects of disease on the gut
microbiome so using a multivariate
analysis we did that both for microbial
taxonomic profiles and for microbial
functional profiles and this is one of
the most important conclusions here in
as much as IBD again appears to be not a
function of specific microbes but of
specific microbial processes just like
what is maintained in the gut and other
microbial communities during health is
not specific organisms but a
distribution of necessary functions what
it is erupted in IBB is not necessarily
specific bugs but a set of microbial
processes that become dis patek in this
case over proportionately over six times
as many as specific organisms
and so the parallel that I would draw
here is in terms of a city's ecology if
there's a problem with the transit
system it's not because of people with a
particular name but with people with a
particular job if there's a dysbiosis
and the gut during IBP it's because of
disruptions to microbial processes in
this case often the response to redox
stress induced by inflammation and
activation of the immune system it
concentrated in particular organisms so
the enter bacteria CA for example are
often enriched during chronic
inflammation such as IPP but the driving
factor is selection on that process not
necessarily a pathogen or specific
organism in the traditional sense
we're continuing work on the IBD
microbiome now during the HMP 2 or
integrative human microbiome project
follow-up to the first wave of the HMP
this is an ongoing study again with Rama
Xavier at the broad and mph in which
we're following 90 individuals drawn
from a variety of IBD phenotypes for one
year each and longitudinally surveying
their gut microbiomes through a variety
of different modalities part of the
Mandate of the HMP 2 is to provide
multi-omics data that really serves a
comprehensive survey of the microbiome
and hosts host molecular responses in
different diseases our project looks at
IPP there are several other hmph YouTube
projects looking at other conditions
such as type 2 diabetes and if you're
interested in more information there you
can check out the IBD MTB or IBD
multi-omics database site on the slide
here the projects still ongoing but to
wrap up with an example we have a pilot
data set in which we've surveyed about
200 gut metagenomes from individuals in
this population accompanying by stool
metabolite profiles so stool
metabolomics we can then ask the
question which microbes are
differentially abundant during from
their colitis and which metabolites are
differentially abundant during Crohn's
or colitis and start associating
compounds with bugs to help explain at
the molecular level why these organisms
and possibly
compounds lately disruptive in disease
so what you're looking at here is a
correlation on rows between bugs and on
columns between metabolites that are
associated with each other over and
above the amount that we'd expect just
from the disease itself so this starts
to suggest that these compounds might be
associated with these four mechanistic
reasons the bug like produced that
compound or consumed that compound and
we're currently doing some genome gazing
to help tease apart those potential
causes and one example that we can
obtain using a specific tool like human
2 is to survey essentially positive
control compounds in this case the bile
acids are known to be disrupted in IBD
different members of the family of bile
acids are either enriched or depleted
during frogs and colitis these are known
microvilli processed compounds that are
generated by the human host and then
processed by microbes in the gut and
what we're looking at here is a subset
of our 200 metagenomes
in which each row picks out one gene
family that's a member of the bile acid
hydrolases which is the first enzyme in
the microbial pathway that processes the
bile acids each row represents one
member of the by ossify hydrolases drawn
from one specific organism if you squint
real hard you can see a gene family
identifier and a microbial taxon
associated with each row a subset of
these specific gene families are again
enriched or depleted during Crohn's and
Colitis and this allows us to make from
high-throughput data very specific
hypotheses that say these bugs are
disrupted in this phenotype due to
changes in these particular Selective
pressures associated with these
particular pathways and in this case
these specific gene families so this is
one way in which we can tie together a
very specific mechanistic molecular
hypothesis about how and why microbial
ecology might be disrupted at a
functional level during a complex
condition such as a phlegm
Peralta's ease our ramp up by pointing
out that the tools used in these
examples and several others are
available on the labs website or the bio
bakery which is a collection of
documentation downloadable software
online tools manuscripts when available
source code hopefully everything you
need to run this family of tools from
metagenome and meta transcriptome
analysis on your own data and again
emphasizing that in as much as there's a
lot that we do know about the human
might provide them so far there's a lot
that's still left to learn ranging from
basic microbiology and mechanism all the
way up to more complex human or
microbial ecology this includes as I
mentioned earlier a whole lot of
functional biochemical dark-matter
sequences that are not yet functionally
characterized either in the photos or on
the host side particularly in terms of
host microbe immune interactions as far
as translating the microbiome again we
have opportunities not just in
Diagnostics to use that the microbiome
is a - put readout of Health but is
intervention it's hard to change our
genomes but it's surprisingly easy to
change our bugs it's just really hard to
do it in a way that does exactly what we
want or induces the phenotype that we'd
like and finally on the public health
and an ethics side there are questions
of for example microbial privacy as
might be raised by the identifiability
study that i mentioned earlier or in
health practices there's a lot of great
work in the field that I haven't
described today on early life exposures
and how perturbations like antibiotics
might induce changes in our microbiome
that are linked to health status later
on in life so with that I'll wrap up
I'll think again the members of my own
lab who did the hard work on all these
projects on the left are great
collaborators in the HMP and the HMP -
on the right particularly brahmic
saviour and turkey burrs who were
involved in pretty much all of these
examples from from beginning to end
wendy garrett at the harvard school of
public health and i'm happy to take any
questions today thanks everyone
well thank you dr. Hutton our that
informative presentation before we begin
the Q&A session I'd like to remind
everyone how to submit their questions
and comments can do so by clicking on
the green Q&A button in the lower left
of the presentation window and typing it
into the Q&A box that appears on the
screen our first question comes from
adesh tree tree removal at rest
consultancy
India and Ataturk University his
question is what is the level of overall
stability or representativeness of human
microbiome microbiome in normal
individuals so the work that I'm
familiar with that has assessed
microbiome stability in the most detail
comes from Jeff Gordon's lab and looks
specifically at that gut they asked the
question with the decay rate for
retention or loss of microbes over time
and what you see is a power-law
distribution in which microbes that are
going to be lost are lost fairly rapidly
after the first week or two subsequent
to sampling
most microbes that made it that far
tended to stick around for months to
years both their survey and the data
that we've looked at during the human
microbiome project ranged out to a
couple of years at most over which time
there was a surprising amount of
stability and an other data that we've
looked at you can't actually see effects
of childhood exposures in adult life so
for example breast feeding or deliver
motor delivery vaginal versus c-section
does leave microbial echoes that you can
see in the microbiome 20 30 40 years
later on so as far as specific microbes
the dynamics tend to be on the order of
weeks to years as far as the overall in
microbial community you can see
configurations effects of exposures that
last certainly years and possibly
decades as well
Thank You our next question comes from
Tobin lka University of Houston this
question is actually graphic refers to
slide 11 in your presentation he's
asking if you could repeat how to read
this graph great I am trying to get us
back to slide 11 in case that will
display as well there we go so in both
this slide and the previous slide on
alpha diversity the slide represents of
theta diversity or differences between
microbial communities each of the
columns along the x-axis represents one
of the 18 body sites surveyed by the HMP
aging box represents the beta diversity
across the population or the aggregate
of all pairwise differences between
individuals at that body site the three
different colors represent three
different ways of processing the HMP
data either our amplicon data directly
classified as phyla types or clustered
as ot us or our shotgun metagenomes
referred to as WGS or whole genome
shotgun data on this particular plot
classified to reference genomes so each
box represents the beta diversity
differences between bugs between
individuals across the whole population
at one body site higher means more
differences and lower means fewer
differences well thank you the next
question is from Fernando hirato I'm hey
at Laval University
why is excuse my pronunciation here why
federal common comfort so they're cold
like cobia is often not found in these
analyses if it is such an abundant phyla
in the gret by crook microbiota
try to jump back we go to the closing
slide if I heard correctly Ruka microvia
is among the claves that can be a little
more difficult to detect either due to
16s primer specificity so when using
employ con data one of the potential
biases is in the different affinity of
specific primers for sub regions or
hypervariable regions of the 16s RNA
gene different affinity in different
organisms so even though many primers
that target different regions of the 16s
gene are referred to as universal among
bacteria they tend to match slightly
better or worse to different organisms
uh Maruca microvia can be under
represented if the primers don't match
their particular 16s variants quite as
well another great example is in one of
the most common primer sets used right
now that targets the V for paper
variable region of the 16s will almost
never see Propionibacterium which is one
of the more common skin microbes
alternatively on the shotgun netted gene
outside one of the reasons that some
clays including sometimes the vertical
microvia are underrepresented is a
dearth of reference information this is
even more common in unusual claves that
aren't well represented a v reference
genome information so if you're not
performing de novo assembly of abundant
microbes in metagenomes it can be hard
to see bugs for which we don't have
enough reference information on the
shotgun side so depending on your your
sequencing type those are two reasons
why the group a microvia and again hop
and other more unusual plates can eat
underrepresented the next question is
from yoga entre Park faculty of biology
University of Belgrade this question is
about this biogeography research of the
microbe
have they observed like male genital
Micro community I apologize that I
didn't point here the tail end of the
question there there have been studies
of both urethral and the general male
genital microbiome as well I'm not
personally familiar with them but I know
there are several that have been
published in the literature thank you
here's another question from Fernando
Flores Oh on yet Laval University what's
your opinion concerning the use of 16s
rRNA based taxonomic profiles to predict
community function by applying
algorithms and wouldn't that be very
limited as it assumes that different
strains of the same phyla type exert the
same functions great this this question
refers indirectly to a tool that we
built with Rob Knight and Rob FICO
referred to as pie crust which will
perform an approximate functional
inference or meta-genome inference from
a taxonomic profile so that the brief
summary is that given a taxonomic
profile of which bugs are present
typically from amplicon sequencing by
combining that with knowledge of which
genes those bugs typically carry from
reference genomes you can make an
informed guess about which genes and
that's what the meta genome looks like
for community you're exactly right in as
much as that is an approximation pie
crust uses ancestral state
reconstruction to make a quantified
guess about which genes each bug
probably carries that comes with
confident confidence intervals based on
how often each gene is observed in
reference sequences to be present in
each isolated genome there are some
genes that are always carried by a
particular clade there are some genomes
that are variable as
of the pan rather than core genome so
pie crust though the best it can it will
provide you with confidence intervals
indicating which genes are less certain
to be in the community and it does
assume that different strains within a
particular clade are equivalent in some
sense to the degree that they can be
resolved by 16s variants I think of this
as a sort of blurry microscope there is
a level of specificity passed which you
can never focus because of that true
biological variability at the tips of
the philosophy so using a particular
marker sequence such as the 16s if there
is genomic diversity that occurs with a
below the level at which variants occur
in the 16s marker then no you won't be
able to see it with amplicon sequencing
on the other hand there is consistent
linkage of function with Falacci it's
diverse but not random such that down to
that level of blurriness you do get a
fairly accurate profile of what the bugs
are probably doing our next question is
from Sanjeet acharya the NCT our fda
what is the best strategy to correlate
microbiome with commune response mucosa
associated microbes stool microbiome etc
if the oppose that associate which site
ileum colon etc great if I interpret
that correctly there's sort of two
questions linked in there one being the
the methods by which you can associate
microbes with phenotype or environment
and the other being the sort of detailed
bio geographical variation and in the
gut itself along the colon for example
so for the for the first question
there's a lot of great work in
biostatistics and computational research
right now in ways of handling microbiome
phenotype Association it's very much the
same way
seiji was associate genetic variance
with veena fights or several years ago
microarrays help to associate
transcription with phenotypes the
methods are often very similar through
tools such as limo from microwaves edgar
de seek for RNA seek data GH DK for
genetics data that all perform the same
kind of fancy t tests and there are
packages out there that will do the same
thing for microbiome we have two
referred to as lefse and Maslin from our
lab to perform univariate and
multivariate tests respectively and
there are several others from other
groups that all do variants on
statistical tests appropriate from
microbial data on the other side of the
question as far as gut biogeography lee
and others have performed some fairly
detailed studies of how stool reflects
different mucosal microbial communities
going along the length of the GI tract
what we found use one example in a
primate model is that stool very well
reflects the colon mucosal community
with a few quantifiable differences so
what we saw there is that overall data
diversity like we saw in the IBD example
in this talk between stool and mucosal
biopsies can be quite high but it's
often driven by changes in just a few
taxa that are much more abundant at the
new cosas or in school and once you
normalize those bugs school really does
well reflect what's going on with
mucosal surface it's true in the colon
if you move up to the small intestine
there's still a high correlation between
the two but the link it is much less
direct and their thirst more noise there
are more differences driven by
differences in biology pH and microbial
density for example between those two
environments
whereas stool along the length of the
colon above luminal contents and school
proper pretty well reflect what's
happening at the colonic mucosa with
those few quantifiable differences
well thank you doctor veterinary it
looks like that's all the time we have
today and so that's that was our last
question first of all I'd like to thank
dr. had an hour and hour audience for
attending today today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
February 2016 you excuse me you will
receive an email from lab roots alerting
you when this webcast will be available
for replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's event meanwhile
thanks again for coming we'll see you
next time goodbye